I saw someone in that bathroom you come
out of that bathroom you're dead really
cuz I got a grenade
I don't care get all died holy crap are
you serious oh my god
hahahahahaha who's left I am but I'm
stuck I can't get out
you stuck let me come assist you please
do wait he's gonna assist you with a
bullet to your head don't let him really
nothing yep I think that's just what I
need
cuz I can't fall out of the ball hockey
oh yeah oh ah brass balls ball deep from
the shadow of my balls it's good yeah
your balls cast a shadow yes they're
that massive oh I hear a sheep gunfire
no you don't so uh uh I think it is acid
you better get way you get a by the
gazebo yes
I mean no oh I have a grenade no you a
zombie with a grenade I got a good day
he's this I've got a thing I'm gonna say
yes how did I kill me yes we go far away
I was so far stealing my booze oh [ __ ]
no can we just run through the lake I
want to see we're gonna run through the
lake well now like this like that
there's nothing what can we eat time ah
another thing well err nope and the
gunfire no get away get away
what the hell you can't grab me ah I see
a policeman one of us you don't see any
oh wait no hit are and then call over
your mom oh this is fun I have to forget
that edge and edge and Mark have not
played against manners in a game where
lying is involved with no we have
I have you don't know you don't know the
awful truth about the banana man hey I'm
actually artists I believe I believe in
the goodness in the nanners yeah I don't
know cippec I found love in a lot of
places there's a bunch of trees in a
medical tent and a lot of spare and
desperation
keep talking we work for that place that
today I am apply the aura of sorrow and
despair I got it it's exactly where i
okay what is it mama
yeah well I think I know what's going on
over here
oh hey oh it's just me and so hard to
find people in your the zombie ah-choo I
think I'm gonna hide I'm not doing very
well as a hunter no this time I'm going
balls out cuz that's how I roll I'm
going balls in right now is that okay to
say okay I said it how many guy dad I'm
going you can have Missouri vagina
determined having vagina is what I'm
doing yeah about China's okay I'm gonna
shoot something look be like that's
vagina shirt too much oh yeah you know
I've seen some vaginas in my time but
this is the most determined in the world
that's out of those half-assed ones it
does everything yourself
oh oh it's not good god no oh man I
survived I didn't suck damn it Oh
good how are you doing I should read
that would have just brought although
they're all gonna come out of shot boss
ah good good
get back here I'm gonna come clean I
wanna nibble on you
all right heads did it take to go to the
center of manga mix guitar god damn it
now this really sounds like a horror
movie
mark yah oh yeah I saw you
Yomi yeah I like this are you Isis are
you in it I got are you just like the
movie is that addiction don't you add
someone ping-mei MA yes how did you
shoot me a lot doing hit a wall
yes who does he know my dick is not the
source of my powers oh come on Nance
it's ours everyone's power ah don't get
me what are you talking about come on no
I'm the nice one
I'm coming for ya okay I'm alright with
this no I can't work no let's go kill
Marty we'll take the penis that is
rightfully mine
how'd you mix I likes getting all those
calls manners it made me feel like I
actually had friends yeah
grenade Oh try [ __ ] hahahaha what was
are you okay baby I just threw a good
day jeez don't take it so personally are
you sure aggravated me not at you how
else am I supposed to take it
mmm give me that body girl I am
weirdo oh no don't get me rip his balls
all right reload a bit it's Tesla losing
a finger to about down we go just
survived a that's what I thought I'm
Clyde dead climbin ah
nearly got mark yeah Oh nearly there we
go just climb it
this is zombie tried to cut me off at
the pass no it's not gonna yeah let's
play on this light mark oh boy
what it totally works he's by the lake
he's by the lake why not
little a I say all wise that's a good
haha no no two bullets
rare [ __ ] reload alright now you're dumb
yeah yeah oh yeah just ad I was closing
on it that's not fair you all went after
B and I'm really on edge right yeah I
can hear and see one of you shooting you
can hear but you can't see my flash see
the bullets flying through the air
there's my guys boom oh thanks what I
left crew you guys left
yep wait did you did you leave did I
leave yes sir hi okay good good ride an
ADIZ in the party home Oh got you I have
you thank you god damn it oh [ __ ] you
your fans from YouTube god damn it you
every place are we're deleting your
channel on YouTube but hit up by
contacts at YouTube HQ hey you're going
down